the best swimmers have the best innate
understanding of hydrodynamics swimming
is all about drag management we want to
be able to make our bodies as long and
slender as possible so that drag doesn't
hinder us with freestyle for example
I've been trying to get better at
decreasing my frontal profile what that
means is I used to extend forward with
there being a pretty big gap between my
shoulder and my jaw and now I try to
make sure that my head is a little
further forward and my shoulder is
extended so that this whole surface is
no longer a drag area just very small
things like that that you would normally
never think of but they make a big
difference over the course of a race
once you get to this level you know once
you're in Olympia it's very very hard to
get better and so we're constantly
looking for very little things that
maybe we can tweak about somebody else
might not see that's from you know
Russia or Australia we're always trying
to stay like one step ahead of the world
before 2011 even I was I was swimming
with disconnections so I've thought
about my kick having a really strong
kick I thought about my arms I didn't
think of everything as one unit once I
found a connection it really took me to
a whole new level a really important
part is timing the correct kick to a
particular movement in your stroke when
you're swimming a butterfly kick a lot
of us are only kicking down and then our
feet are sort of floating up the best
people in the world are kicking up and
down and so you're getting propulsion
from both and freestyle for instance at
the top your stroke the first thing you
want to do when you catch is is kick
with that same leg but you need to be
able to transfer that energy and that
momentum through your hips through your
core into your shoulders you have to
stay connected through your whole body
from your head to your core all the way
to pointing your feet when you're
kicking it looks very smooth and we're
make but I flex my ABS almost as hard as
I can and use my cores leverage swimming
from side to side you have to work on
your core because all the strokes
basically start from the core rocket
calls it the canoe where I just set my
anchor and then twist my core and use
that leverage to pull just really using
my whole body we're always changing up
little stroke techniques to try and
become a faster swimmer for me it's just
instead of keeping my hands closed
keeping my hands a little open you
actually pull more water when your hands
are a little bit open in your swimming
stroke it takes countless hours of hard
work and dedication a lot of commitment
and a lot of sacrifices you need to be
willing to go that extra mile it's so
easy to just show up to practice or show
up in the weight room and go through the
motions but if you're truly invested and
you know that's what you want to do
that's what makes you champion